Nous rentrons dans cette nouvelle série en faisant la transition des dix commandements
envers la lettre d'épaule aux Galates et c'est quelque part deux événements qui sont
fondationnels dans la vie du peuple de Dieu.
Moïse quelque part est devenu d'une fois pour toutes les grands paradigmes pour la
suite de l'histoire d'Israël jusqu'à ce que Christ arrive.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer comment dans les Pentateuches nous avons un exode,
la présentation la plus compacte et concise de la loi et en Deutéronome nous allons voir
quelque part la manière dont Moïse va non seulement rappeler la loi à cette génération
qui n'était pas là au moment de la livraison de la loi mais il va rappeler en portant un
peu plus d'explications, un peu plus d'éclarté, un peu plus d'implications.
Et quelque part, moi je fais partie en fait, après avoir pas mal étudié, de ceux
qui considèrent Galate comme l'une des premières lettres d'épaule si ce n'est pas la première,
surtout par son rapport envers Romain.
Et c'est intéressant de remarquer comment Galate il semble être la pierre angulaire si
on peut dire comme ça, ou la fondation, la contribution Pauline pour la compréhension
de ce qu'est le christianisme dans ce nouveau scénario mondial.
Surtout que le christianisme n'est pas l'une des sectes qui ont dérivé du judaïsme,
mais comment le christianisme a cette indépendance, même par rapport à la conception juive.
Et c'est important qu'on comprenne cette contribution d'Epaul, mais que nous voyons en fait les rapports
entre cette défense d'Epaul qui était l'un des plus zélés envers la loi, avant sa conversion,
l'un des plus préparés à comprendre la loi.
Il a appris des Gamaliel lui-même, il était une étoile qui s'élevait entre tous ceux qui étaient dans sa génération,
dans les judaïsmes.
Mais Dieu l'a choisi particulièrement pour porter ses messages aux païens.
toute cette préparation pour qu'ils soient capables d'expliquer aux païens que nous n'avons pas besoin
de rituels juifs.
Et c'est très important, car Paul sera si passionné dans cette lettre, avec un cœur si pastoral,
que si nous ne comprenons pas très bien quelle était la problématique à l'église des Galates,
nous courons les risques d'avoir la sensation qu'il est en train de rejeter complètement la loi.
Et c'est ça qui est important, les enjeux qui seront là.
Et donc nous avons fait ces mouvements des dix commandements vers les Galates
pour qu'on puisse comprendre la perspective de tous les nouveaux testaments quelque part
vis-à-vis à la loi et des Paul lui-même qu'on a bien compris.
Il a vu la portion favorable de la loi.
Et en fait, nous avons pris cette décision à cette église car nous croyons
que c'est les modèles bibliques pour qu'on expose la parole de Dieu.
Donc il y a des différentes manières de prêcher la parole de Dieu,
mais malheureusement, ni toutes les manières de prêcher la parole de Dieu sont bibliques.
Juste pour donner un exemple, lorsque je vous parle,
et nous prenons du temps dans nos prédications pour ça,
nous cherchons toujours à prendre un moment pour vous convaincre
que ce qui sera parlé, ce qui sera mis en emphase,
ce qui va devoir impliquer dans la transformation de vos comportements,
n'est pas quelque chose qui appartient à mes propres idées.
Je prends du temps pour vous expliquer qui c'est que je vous enseigne,
ce n'est pas ma vérité, mais c'est la vérité biblique.
Et je vous enseigne par là à interpréter la Bible correctement.
Car lorsque vous allez étudier vos Bibles, vous devez d'abord considérer
qu'est-ce que la Bible parle, qu'elle est son objectif dans son contexte.
Et lorsque nous entendons des prédicateurs qui exigent de nous
qu'il y ait de l'exhortation, qui sont plus préoccupés à démontrer
les implications pratiques que vous sortez avec un serment noté par trois points, etc.,
on n'est pas toujours si clair d'où nous sommes partis.
Elle est l'autorité de ce qu'il dit.
Avant de penser à comment je vais vivre ma vie,
je dois me demander la question, mais pourquoi je dois vivre la vie comme ça ?
Donc nous avons besoin des doctrines, d'explications des vérités bibliques,
d'assurance que ces vérités sont originaires des dieux lui-même,
de comprendre ces explications,
donc vérité, autorité, vérité, expliqué et appliqué.
Et quand on va non seulement par les enregistrements des serments bibliques,
nous voyons prédominamment ces paramètres,
quelle est l'autorité de ce qu'il dit ?
C'est une autorité des Écritures, des Écrits saints, la Bible, Dieu lui-même.
Quelle est la vérité ? Quelle est son explication ?
Doctrine.
Et ensuite, application.
Voilà pourquoi vous devez vivre de cette manière.
Donc les modèles prédominants des serments enregistrés dans la Bible,
comme les serments sur la montagne par exemple.
Mais quand on considère les lettres,
c'est assez intéressant.
Car les lettres, elles ont une nature,
ou les épîtres plutôt,
elles ont une nature, un estil littéraire propre.
Et c'est très intéressant.
La grande différence entre les lettres de l'époque
et les épîtres bibliques néo-testamentaires,
c'est qu'elles nous donnent l'impression,
c'est leur objectif,
que ce sont des homilies ou des serments rédigés.
rédigés.
C'est comme si on était en train d'enregistrer
les serments qui étaient prêchés.
Donc l'objectif d'épauler par ces lettres
n'est pas de produire un travail académique,
il était en pleine mission,
persécuté partout.
C'était son cœur passionné,
pastoral,
qui prenait soin des églises qu'il avait implantées,
ou d'autres apôtres avaient implantées.
Mais son objectif,
c'était toujours de produire une transformation légitime,
d'apporter la préservation
de ceux qui étaient exposés au danger,
aux hérésies,
aux faux maîtres,
à la fausse religion.
Et donc les épîtres,
surtout les épîtres d'épaule,
elles sont chargées des passions,
elles sont chargées d'émotions,
d'affections.
Et nous allons voir comment Paul,
dans son aspect raisonnable,
ses lettres sont vraiment très riches,
elles surmontent même la capacité d'argumentation,
des pensées les plus brillantes de son époque,
mais son travail n'était pas strictement académique.
Il ne laisse rien désiré dans cet aspect-là,
la logique, la clarté.
Mais il va toujours au-delà.
Il va toujours dans la direction de l'affection,
des émotions,
de la transformation pratique,
de nos vies.
Et bon,
quand on considère les lettres,
et quand on considère les sermons illustrés dans la Bible,
nous voyons la structure qui doit nous guider
quand on va prêcher un serment.
Nous devons lire
Paul, apôtre,
non de la part des hommes,
ni par un homme,
mais par Jésus-Christ,
et Dieu le Père qui a ressuscité des morts,
et tous les frères qui sont avec moi,
aux églises de la Galatie,
que la grâce et la paix
vous soient données de la part des dieux,
les Pères et de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
qui s'est donné lui-même pour nos péchés,
afin de nous arracher du présent siècle mauvais,
selon la volonté de Dieu notre Père,
à qui soit la gloire,
au siècle des siècles.
Amen.
Verset 6.
Je m'étonne que vous vous détourniez si promptement
de celui qui vous appelait à la grâce de Christ
pour passer à notre évangile.
Donc on voit déjà comment
sa doctrine va déclencher en louange
à qui soit la gloire.
Il vient de présenter l'évangile dans sa clarté,
dans sa concision.
C'est son introduction.
Il va déjà exploser en louange
à qui soit la gloire des siècles et des siècles.
Et devant la gloire des siècles évangiles
qui avait été présentée avec excitante clarté,
il va démontrer aussi son étonnement
envers ses auditeurs.
Et donc c'est quelque chose
de très urgent que nous voyons ici,
mais tout d'abord,
je voulais juste vous expliquer
pourquoi nous cherchons
à présenter des expositions,
si on peut dire comme ça,
textuelles la parole de Dieu,
de suivre des livres en entier.
C'est car cela nous donne plus d'assurance
que nous sommes en train
de bien comprendre les contextes
et ce que Dieu a voulu parler
à cette époque-là
afin qu'on ne nous détourne pas
des vérités qui servent pour toujours.
Et lorsque nous suivons
toute la longueur des textes bibliques,
au lieu d'être pendant la semaine
désespérés en train de chercher
un texte pour prêcher
et de croire que toute la parole
est inspirée des dieux,
nous nous protégeons aussi
de faire de la Bible notre tâche.
Nous sommes otages des Écritures
quand on doit prêcher
tous les textes qui nous attendent.
Je ne suis pas esclave
de mes faiblesses particulières.
Je ne vais pas éviter
de prêcher certains textes
qui me défient.
Au contraire,
je vais m'exposer
à tous les coups
que la parole de Dieu
puisse me frapper
afin que je sois transformé
à la parole de Dieu.
Et je ne suis pas, donc,
sous l'addiction
ou la tendance
de limiter
la compréhension biblique
du peuple
à mes limitations
et préférences
vis-à-vis
mes textes préférés
de l'Écriture.
Et donc, nous avons la conviction
que la meilleure manière
que Dieu a choisi
pour faire des disciples
dans un corps,
dans une Église,
c'est à travers la prédication.
Et la prédication
d'exposition textuelle.
Et donc, voilà,
nous nous préparons
et nous nous rappelons
que notre objectif
est toujours,
non tout simplement,
la transmission d'informations,
mais la transformation
en conformité
à l'Évangile de Jésus-Christ.
Notre objectif,
c'est toujours
l'adoration
et la sanctification.
En plus,
qu'on doit beaucoup étudier
pour comprendre
les textes bibliques,
nous ne devons jamais
perdre de vue
que l'objectif,
c'est que la gloire de Dieu
soit rendue visible
en Jésus-Christ.
Et la chose la plus importante
à présenter au peuple,
c'est toujours
vous êtes devant
la gloire de Dieu.
Vivez à cette lumière.
Jamais de l'intérêt
strictement intellectuel.
Et je voulais dire
donc quelques vérités
à propos
d'introduction
de cette lettre
de Paul
pour que nous puissions
garder
toutes ces choses-là
dans ce cadre.
Nous allons chercher
à faire une exposition
textuelle
des Galates.
Donc, notre objectif,
c'est de contempler
la gloire de Dieu
révélée dans l'Évangile
afin que nos vies
soient transformées
en conformité
à Jésus-Christ.
Notre objectif,
c'est l'adoration
et la sanctification.
Et nous devons garder
ces considérations
surtout quand on considère
l'introduction
d'un livre biblique.
Il y a beaucoup
de technicités
historiques,
littéraires
et c'est surtout important
à ce moment-là
de nous rappeler
que toutes ces choses
auront des implications
pour la suite,
pour notre compréhension
de la lettre,
pour notre adoration
à Dieu
et notre sanctification.
Donc, pour ce qui concerne
une introduction
historique,
littéraire,
si on peut dire
comme ça,
comment cette lettre
a été composée,
quel est son style,
quels étaient
les contextes historiques,
donc c'est important
de considérer
toutes ces choses-là
car nous avons besoin
de considérer
plus ou moins
quels étaient
les contextes,
même si les contenus
de cette lettre
sont très clairs,
c'est important
de considérer
quels étaient
les enjeux,
les problèmes
vécus
dans ces églises
pour voir
quelles similarités
nous sommes
en train de vivre
avec eux
aujourd'hui
et voir
la juste application
et appliquer
les justes remèdes
pour chaque tentation,
pour chaque menace
que nous allons trouver
et donc c'est surtout
important
de considérer
ces attributs
des la lettre.
Donc on commence
par une considération
sur son style littéraire
dont je vous ai déjà parlé,
donc c'est une épître
et donc l'épître
elle vise
à représenter
un serment
rédigé
et l'élément
d'interaction
il est très important,
l'élément
d'exhortation,
pourquoi Paul
s'est montré
si passionné,
c'est pas qu'il n'était
pas capable
de se comprendre
pour produire
un document
littéraire
académique,
intellectuel,
une défense
tout simplement
philosophique,
car c'est très intéressant
quand on compare,
quand les spécialistes
comparent
ces éléments
des épîtres
qui sont très riches
car ils ont des éléments
qui sont très similaires
au langage
des juridiques romans
ou aux capacités
d'argumentation
grecques,
philosophiques.
Mais ce qui restera
le plus pour nous
c'est l'inspiration
des pôles
et son cœur
pastoral
et missionnaire
et le fait
qu'il était
un ambassadeur.
c'est pas
qu'on doit
étudier
la philosophie grecque
ou
la loi romaine
pour comprendre
quels sont les
recours qu'il utilise.
Toutes ces choses
ont été plutôt naturelles
pour lui
car il était
formé
et un produit
quelque part
de son époque.
Mais ce qu'on voit
dans ces lettres
c'est l'apôtre.
C'est l'homme
inspiré des dieux.
C'est quelqu'un
qui nous parle
et nous entendons
la voix des dieux.
Et la réalité
c'est qu'il va faire
recours de plusieurs choses
de manière plutôt
spontanée et naturelle
qui est très conscient
de ce qu'il fait.
Donc l'objectif
de la lettre
c'est pas
de nous enseigner
par exemple
et c'est ça
qu'il faut faire attention
quand on étudie
les contextes historiques
qu'on doit avoir
plus des leçons
des rhétoriques.
Donc on doit avoir
plus des leçons
d'homalétique
de savoir comment communiquer
comment persuader
Paul lui-même
on va dire plus tard
dans une autre lettre
quand j'étais entre vous
c'était pas par langage
des persuasions humaines.
J'ai décidé
de rien savoir entre vous
qu'écrit
ce célestis glorifié.
Donc quand on contemple
en Paul
pour plus que ces lettres
soient louables
dans les aspects
philosophiques
ou des conceptions
logiques
ce qu'on doit
s'appeler toujours
c'est que ces lettres
prévaux
car
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui parle à travers Paul
et c'est un Paul
avec un coeur pastoral
qui cherche
l'interaction
entre Dieu.
Il dit ça
nous sommes comme
des ministres de Dieu
c'est comme si Dieu
parlait à travers nous.
C'est comme
Black Jones
il disait
c'est lorsque
je commence mon serment
vous êtes là
en train de prendre
des notes
ok c'est pas grave
je suis content
vous essayez
de vous accrocher
et si lorsque
j'ai fini mon serment
vous êtes toujours là
avec vos notes
j'ai l'impression
que moi j'ai échoué
et pourquoi il disait ça
car il ne suivait pas
les tendances
de son époque
de se sentir
sous l'obligation
de présenter aux personnes
trois points
avec lesquels
ils puissent sortir
pour savoir comment
appliquer leur vie
avec des buts
des propositions
mais qui Dieu parle
à travers la prédication
et à un moment donné
on peut laisser tomber
nos stylos
et entendre
ce que Dieu
veut nous dire
c'est légitime
parfois
d'enseigner
par exemple
en parlant des Galates
l'introduction
je pourrais aujourd'hui
afficher les maps
etc.
je pense que ça serait
un outil profitable
mais de faire
de ces modèles là
l'usage des diapos
des modèles
des prédications
c'est quelque chose
qui je pense
qui pourrait être
questionnable bibliquement
pourquoi ?
car l'objectif
de la prédication
c'est que les personnes
qui soient présentes
aient la certitude
qu'il y a une interaction
entre Dieu
la vérité de Dieu
et moi
il veut transformer
quelque chose chez moi
c'est pas à moi
de contrôler
les points
c'est bien de nous rappeler
je ne m'oppose pas
que vous preniez des notes
c'est pas ça
c'est ce qu'il a dit
je voulais communiquer
mais ce qu'il veut communiquer
c'est que
les prédicateurs
doivent toujours
se garder
pour plus
qu'ils doivent toujours
avoir une structure
je ne suis pas en train
de dire
il faut qu'ils soient
perdus
dans son futur
au contraire
mais il faut
qu'ils gardent toujours
une grande portion
de liberté
pour qu'ils puissent
laisser ses notes
sonore
à un moment donné
et permettre
que les Saint-Esprits
nous parlent
avec puissance
basé sur les textes
donc c'est important
de considérer
cet aspect littéraire
qui nous laisse
des grandes leçons
pour nos vies
pour nos prédications
et voilà pourquoi
Lloyd Jones
il disait
voilà pourquoi
moi je ne donne pas
un programme
vous pouvez savoir
quelle sera
la prédication
du dimanche prochain
ça sera les prochains versets
ça c'est clair
mais il ne se donnait pas
des limites
un planning annuel
même certains
peuvent faire ça
ils le font bien
je ne suis pas en train
de mépriser totalement
mais pour lui
il préférait
garder les rythmes
qui permettent
un peu plus
des libertés
pour bien traiter
les choses
avant d'avancer
pour être sûr
qu'on a bien compris
les textes
avant de donner
les prochains pas
et nous allons
être transformés
comme ça
progressivement
il vaut mieux
faire tomber
un géant
à chaque fois
que d'essayer
de métrailler
toute l'armée
ennemie
tous sont blessés
mais au camp
on a été mis à mort
donc la réalité
biblique
il faut qu'on respecte
c'est
ce que les textes
nous donnent
à chaque fois
et donc l'épître
son estile
était celle-là
donc je vous rappelle
Paul
il était particulièrement
destiné
à l'oeuvre
d'un évangéliste
et l'évangéliste
selon la Bible
ok
en tant qu'apôtre
même en tant qu'apôtre
il n'était pas fixé
la plupart du temps
comme par exemple
certains apôtres
à Jérusalem
mais Paul
il était impliqué
dans l'implantation
d'église
l'évangélisation
de Paul
n'a jamais été marquée
par une évangélisation
détachée
d'implantation
d'église
parce que Dieu
a dit
lorsqu'il Christ a dit
allez
faites des disciples
de toutes les nations
les disciples
qui sont devenus apôtres
ce qu'ils ont fait
c'était d'implanter
d'église
en tous les lieux
donc il n'y avait pas
de mouvement
d'évangélisation
déconnecté d'église
dans les Nouveaux Testaments
Paul
il était en train
d'implanter
les églises
étaient implantées
par un premier voyage
et parfois même pas
par Paul
des églises spontanées
par des chrétiens
qui s'organisaient
dans des églises
mais il revenait
pour visiter ces églises
pour affirmer ces églises
en pointant
des anciens
donc l'église
elle était considérée
comme stable
selon les Nouveaux Testaments
lorsqu'elle avait
des anciens
et Paul
donc s'est reporté
à ces églises
avec une supervision
en prenant des nouvelles
par lettres
et en répondant
par des épîtres
et donc Paul
dans cet épître là
à nouveau
son objectif
c'est supervision
affermissement
correction
encouragement
profondément
engagé
émotionnellement
surtout avec
ceux qui étaient
les fruits
de son ministère
et même si Philippiens
c'est peut-être
la lettre
dont nous
contemplons
les plus
les plaisirs
des Paul
envers ses enfants
même si Galate
est une lettre
prédominément
marquée
par des réproches
il les considère
comme des enfants
c'est son
c'est la chaleur
des émotions
du soin
maternel
car à la fin
de la lettre
il va dire
je souffre encore
des douleurs
d'enfantement
pour engendrer
Christ en vous
les mêmes douleurs
que j'ai souffert
lorsque j'étais
entre vous
pour implanter
cette église
c'est comme si
à nouveau
je traverse
ces douleurs là
afin de vous voir
protégés
affirmés
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
les niveaux d'affection
que Paul avait
pour ces églises
et voilà pourquoi
les épîtres permettent
que les travails
ne soient pas
si académiques
que les travails
puissent
transpirer
l'amour de Paul
pour ces églises
il va défendre
son autorité
apostolique
au départ
de cette lettre
Paul apôtre
nom de la part
des hommes
c'est intéressant
et nous allons
comprendre pourquoi
et Paul
il va dédier
les deux premiers chapitres
presque dans sa totalité
à démontrer
que même s'il n'était
pas compté
entre les douze disciples
qui ont vécu
avec Jésus
pendant sa vie
il a été commissionné
directement
par Jésus Christ
il va défendre
son ministère apostolique
afin de laisser
très clair pour nous
quelle est la base
de son inspiration
sa doctrine centrale
qui sera présentée
c'est la justification
par la foi
et ensuite
il va apporter
les implications
pratiques
donc la suture
de la lettre
c'est les paramètres
pour notre suture
pour les sermons
autorité
c'est l'inspiration
apostolique
pour nous
ça reste encore
l'inspiration apostolique
la doctrine centrale
basée sur
l'inspiration
de Dieu
c'est la justification
par la foi
et l'implication
pour la vie pratique
c'est les conséquences
de la justification
par la foi
dans nos vies pratiques
envers la sanctification
voilà la suture
de la lettre
de l'apôtre Paul
ensuite
il y a
une question
qui est particulièrement
intéressante
c'est la considération
des destinataires
et de la date
donc c'est peut-être
la question
la plus difficile
quand on traite
la lettre des Galates
c'est de savoir
qui étaient les publics
qui étaient les personnes
qui ont reçu cette lettre
donc c'est clair
qu'il s'agissait
des églises
qui connaissaient
Paul et Barnabas
car on va voir
dans Galates
que Barnabas
est mentionné
et au début
de la lettre
nous voyons
aux églises
qui sont
en Galatie
donc
verset 2
aux églises
de la Galatie
et donc c'est important
de remarquer
qui sont
ou quelles sont
ces églises là
donc c'est intéressant
de nous rappeler
donc Paul
il va faire la distinction
tout au long
de son ministère
dans tout le long
de ses lettres
entre les églises
avec un n' minuscule
et l'église
avec un n' majuscule
donc le fait
qu'il dit
aux églises
en Galatie
c'est important
car ça nous rappelle
que les églises
étaient organisées
avec une certaine
autonomie
les unes
entre les autres
mais tous
ou toutes
sous
l'autorité apostolique
toutes les églises
devraient suivre
et ces églises
elles sont
super importantes
pour nous
car ces premières églises
elles sont importantes
non tout simplement
car elles avaient été
implantées par les apôtres
par Paul
mais c'est surtout
car par les échanges
que Paul
ou les apôtres
ont eu avec ces églises là
lorsque nous les considérons
comme les fondements
de l'église
les apôtres
les douze
les seuls douze
c'est important
de remarquer
que ces textes
car ils étaient
des apôtres
sont reconnus
comme inspirés
et les traitements
qu'il a donnés
à ces églises là
restent jusqu'aujourd'hui
pour nous
la seule base d'autorité
pour savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire attention
comment on doit gérer
l'église
comment on peut
bâtir l'église
c'est car
ils ont répondu
aux problématiques
ou ils ont fait
des éloges
envers des églises
de cette époque là
donc leur importance
elle est là
surtout pour
l'occasion
qu'elles ont donnée
pour que les nouveaux
testaments
soient enregistrés
et donc
quand on considère
la distinction
qu'il peut le faire
donc au verset 13
du chapitre 1
Paul va dire
j'ai persécuté
l'église du Christ
là c'est sa compréhension
donc à la fin
dans l'aspect invisible
si on peut dire comme ça
il y a une sur l'église
le corps du Christ
mais dans l'église visible
il y a beaucoup
d'imperfections
d'imposteurs même
parmi nous
mais quand même
Paul est en train
de reconnaître
l'importance
des églises locales
et donc il va faire
la distinction
entre église
plus réelle
des Galaties
et l'église des dieux
mais donc
quelles sont ces églises
des Galaties
donc qui sont
les Galates
d'abord
c'est la première question
car la région
était appelée Galatie
à l'époque
des Paul
mais cette région
avait été
agrandie
et la grande question
qu'on se pose là
quand on pense
qui sont les dessinataires
c'est
est-ce que ce sont
les Galates
ethniques
la culture
prédominamment
Galate
qui était là
ou si c'est la région
de la Galatie
dont la portion
sud
était rajoutée
plus tard
mais qui n'était pas
prédominamment
marquée
par
la présence
des Galates ethniques
plutôt
des friges
des romans
des peuples mixés
qui habitaient
dans la région
et qui avaient
une autre caractéristique
et c'est intéressant
donc on fait
beaucoup d'études
on étudie
l'histoire
et aussi
les évidences internes
entre les autres lettres
des Paul
donc les plus importants
c'est pas citant
pour comprendre
les contextes
des églises en soi
mais c'est important
pour dater la lettre
et pour savoir
par exemple
si la lettre
a été
l'une des premières
des Paul
ou l'une des dernières
ce qui est très important
pour considérer
cette contribution
et donc je vous partage
mes conclusions
je vous encourage
à chercher
par vous-même après
mais je vous rappelle
les plus importants
pour les contenus
de la lettre
n'est pas dans cette discussion
ce sont plutôt
des implications
pour comprendre
quels sont
surtout
l'impact
de cette lettre
envers
par exemple
Romain
est-ce que Romain
était écrit d'abord
ou Galate
et donc moi
je suis de la position
que cette lettre
a été écrite
juste après
la première voyage
missionnaire
des Paul
avant les concis
de Jérusalem
ok
ça c'est un point
important
que nous allons voir
avec plus de calme
et bon
Galatie
fait rapport
au Galate
ou les Gaulois
qui veut dire
guerrier
ou Galate
notre nom
qui s'appliquait
au même peuple
qui signifie
noble
quand on pense
au contexte
nous pensons
que cette ethnie
était plutôt
orgueilleuse
de son histoire
donc ils sont
partis
de l'Europe
envers l'Asie mineure
en 1278
avant Jésus Christ
après la mort
d'Alexandre III
et donc
ils ont envahi
les régions
de Grèce
et de l'Asie mineure
et ils se sont placés
dans cette région
qu'aujourd'hui
à la Turquie
donc ils étaient
donc marqués
donc ce sont les Celtes
comme on connait bien
ils étaient marqués
par leur capacité
dans plusieurs endroits
de présenter
une plus forte résistance
à l'Empire romain
à la domination romaine
et jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivaient
à cette position là
marqués
par une grande expansion
dans leur histoire
donc un peuple
qui pouvait être fier
d'eux-mêmes
et qui avait
la caractéristique
d'une espèce
de polythéisme
superstitieux
c'est la superstition
qui faisait partie
de leur mentalité
s'il y a eu
une influence
des Galates ethniques
dans l'église
des Galates
dans la lettre
c'est cette influence
envers la superstition
ça c'est important
pour nous de considérer
car c'était des personnes
qui étaient sauvées
et qui ont compris
l'évangile
au départ
comme nous sommes sauvés
par Christ seulement
mais qui avaient une tendance
de faire confiance
à certains objets matériels
à certains rituels
comme si les choses
pouvaient nous protéger
ou la performance
et quand on pense
aux implications
pour aujourd'hui
on a de l'eau bénie
on a des huiles
qu'on va mettre partout
on a des pratiques
qu'on a prises d'habitude
et il faut faire attention
même
à toute démonstration
matérielles
physique
rituelles
qu'on ait l'impression
qu'ils puissent nous protéger
donc il y a
une implication
qui va par là
donc
ils sont partis
en 1278
ils sont arrivés
à la Zéminère
ils sont restés
là-bas
pendant longtemps
en 189
les romans
l'ont dominé
mais ont permis
qu'ils soient
des royaumes clients
ou dépendants
ils avaient la ruse
d'être toujours d'accord
avec les plus puissants
mais plus tard
en 25 avant Christ
là ils sont
déterminément
dévelus
Provence romaine
et là nous sommes
dans les territoires romans
ils sont complètement
soumis aux romans
et donc les peuples
qui étaient là
ces ethniques gaulois
ils sont déjà
un peu mélangés
avec les influences
du polythéisme romain
la structure romaine
ils gardaient
la capacité
de parler leur dialecte
mais ils parlaient
aussi
les grecs
et donc
s'ils étaient en contact
avec les peuples du sud
là
ils étaient aussi
influencés
par la mixture
de leurs origines
et
une religion
des mystères
et ça c'est important
aussi pour comprendre
pourquoi Paul va faire
appel
d'un certain point
à cette notion
d'avoir reçu
la révélation
du Seigneur
sans faire
beaucoup de réservations
il y a
la notion
une influence
légèrement
gnostique
ou qui précède
les gnostices
qu'elle a
déjà dans cette lettre
donc
la conclusion
à laquelle je suis arrivé
par mes études
c'est que
nous sommes plutôt
devant les églises
du sud
la mention
des Barnabas
est importante
et
les discussions
qui se passent
en Galate
sont aussi importantes
pourquoi ?
car ça serait
surprenant
qu'après les conciles
de Jérusalem
on soit en train
de vivre
ces types
de problématiques
et de difficultés
nous allons voir ça
pour la suite
donc pour moi
c'est
les succès
de la première mission
des pôles
avec Barnabas
juste
après
cette mission
ils ont écrit
la lettre
pour traiter
cet épisode
donc la date
pour nous
c'est
donc un peu avant
l'année 49-50
où nous avons
les conciles
de Jérusalem
et donc ça
c'est un aspect
important
pour nous déconcilier
pour comprendre
la subtilité
car c'était
des églises
qui étaient
implantées
par l'apôtre
Paul lui-même
l'un des plus
capables
de présenter
les saluts
cédons
par la foi
indépendamment
de vos performances
de vos rapports
à la loi
c'est
l'obéissance
parfaite
de Jésus-Christ
à la loi
qui vous a sauvés
et pourquoi
vous voulez revenir
en arrière
aujourd'hui
quelle subtilité
comment ces peuples
qui avaient été
ils n'étaient pas juifs
il y avait des juifs
de la dispersion
qui habitaient là aussi
mais ils n'étaient pas juifs
ils étaient
prédominamment
des païens
soit des païens
d'éthignies galassiennes
d'éthignies mixtes
mais ils n'étaient pas
donnés à la loi
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
chez eux
quelle espèce
des inclinations
envers les mystères
envers la superstition
quelle espèce
d'orgueil
pour pouvoir mériter
les bénédictions
des dieux
pourquoi nous sommes
tous tentés
jusqu'aujourd'hui
même après avoir compris
que les saluts
se donnent par la foi
que nous devons
nous sentir bien
avec Dieu
qu'est-ce que nous sommes
très performants
pourquoi nous nous
nous attachons encore
à ces idées là
qu'on nous présente
aujourd'hui
superstitieuses
donc regardons
la subtilité
par lesquelles
nous sommes attrapés
par ces arrière-plans
donc
quand on contemple
cette question
des dessinateurs
même si nous ne pouvons
pas arriver
à des conclusions
qui soient
très claires
nous pouvons quand même
comprendre un peu
les contextes généraux
et voir comment ces influences
sont là
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui
Galate dans l'histoire
j'ouvre une parenthèse
très importante
donc Galate a toujours
joué un rôle
très important
dans l'histoire
de la foi chrétienne
Chrysostom
pendant la patristique
peut-être celui
qui a fait
la meilleure exposition
des Galates
donc il a été
quelque part
en opposition
à l'interprétation
d'Origène
je vous rappelle
Origen c'était
quelqu'un des magistrales
mais
il avait la tendance
et il a établi
en fait
cette méthode
d'interprétation
qui est connue
comme allégorique
et comme Paul va faire
une allégorie
pendant cette lettre
il va utiliser ça
pour base
pour justifier
sa méthode d'interprétation
donc Paul va dire
il y a
Sarah et Agar
donc la femme d'Abraham
sa servante
et par là
il va faire l'allégorie
entre la foi
et les autres
car Agar
c'était
une solution
charnelle
humaine
pour trouver
la promesse
ou la bénédiction
donc c'est la servante
Sarah a dit à Abraham
tu es l'enfant
de cette femme
car elle n'est pas
stérile
et donc c'est la naissance
d'Ismaël
il va dire là
c'est la démonstration
du fruit
de nos efforts humains
et là
cette femme sera
virée
chassée
et donc Paul va dire
voilà comment ça marche
tous ceux qui veulent vivre
avec Dieu
basés sur la performance
ils seront chassés
mais quand on considère
Sarah
qu'est-ce qu'on voit par là
c'est une femme stérile
et Dieu
prend les crédits
de toute la promesse
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui opère les miracles
qui apporte cet enfant
donc la foi
c'est la démonstration
que ce sont ceux
qui sont nés des dieux
c'est l'oeuvre des dieux
c'est l'oeuvre d'un seul
et donc
c'est une allégorie
qui Paul prend
c'est une chose
qui est Paul
l'auteur
inspiré
face des interprétations
allégoriques
c'est autre chose
qui nous
les êtres humains
nous osons faire
des interprétations
allégoriques
comme si on avait
toute la liberté
pour interpréter
n'importe qui
ou n'importe quoi
à partir des écritures
et donc
Chrysostome
il s'est attaché
à l'interprétation
sur le littéral
si
nous n'avons pas
la certification
des auteurs apostoliques
eux-mêmes
pour interpréter
des aspects allégoriques
dans la Bible
nous n'osons pas
faire des interprétations
allégoriques
et c'est intéressant
car Calvin
c'est lui
qui va arriver
dans la période
de la réforme
et qui va
à nouveau
car même s'il y a
un changement
chez Chrysostome
c'est qu'il y a
un Calvin
que nous allons voir
une opposition
frontale
à la méthode
et à l'école
d'interprétation
d'allégorie
à un moment donné
j'ai entendu
une prédication
où les messieurs
disaient
parlant des Sanson
qu'il était là
au milieu
de cette bataille
et il était
complètement perdu
mais lorsqu'il a vu
les ossements
d'un âne
il a pris
la machoie de l'âne
et il a
conquéris ses ennemis
il a fratté
tous ses ennemis
il a expliqué par là
une interprétation
allégorique
il disait
ça c'est un enseignement
que lorsqu'on pense
qu'on aura
aucune chose
pour nous défendre
Dieu va pouvoir
en moyen
mais ce n'est pas
l'enseignement biblique
clair
c'est que cet homme
qui avait été interdit
de toucher aux morts
à cause de son
voeu des naziréens
il a désobéi
Dieu pour essayer
de régler son problème
par ses propres manières
et c'est pour ça
qu'il va trouver
plusieurs mauditions
malédictions
par la suite
dans sa vie
donc nous ne pouvons pas
faire des interprétations
allégoriques
ou prendre David
par exemple
et Goliath
comme s'il était
nos challenges
dans la vie
Goliath n'est pas
nos challenges
dans la vie
il représente
la paralysation
d'Israël
et David
ne nous représente
pas si tant
il représente
Jésus lui-même
c'est par qui
les géants
qui nous paralysent
c'est la mise à mort
donc il faut
qu'on fasse attention
quand on considère
la parole de Dieu
car les implications
des enseignements
bibliques
sont toujours
supérieures
aux nôtres
même si parfois
ce que nous sommes
en train d'enseigner
par allégorie
est biblique
ce n'est pas
les bons traitements
des écritures
ça c'est important
à considérer
donc Galate
quand on pense à Galate
dans l'histoire
nous pensons
clairement
à l'importance
de cette lettre
pour la définition
de la méthode
d'interprétation
la plus fidèle
aux écritures
et nous pouvons
penser surtout
à Luther
dans la période
de la réforme
c'est peut-être
les scénarios
qui s'approchent
les plus
de la condition
des Galates
au long de l'histoire
combien l'église
elle avait été
c'est intéressant
car les opposants
des Galates
ne sont pas
les mêmes opposants
des Romains
les opposants
sont des païens
et aussi des Juifs
mais c'est plutôt
la notion générale
de la loi des dieux
Paul il est calme
c'est une défense
plutôt théologique
qui est là
et qui est défendue
avec calme
avec beaucoup d'arguments
en Galate
ce sont des personnes
qui ne sont pas
en train de régner Jésus
comme les catholiques
n'étaient pas en train
de régner Jésus
ni Jésus
comme moyen de salut
mais c'est de dire
Jésus n'est pas suffisant
c'est entre nous
la subtilité
la sémence
c'est vous avez besoin
de Jésus
plus quelque chose
et c'est ça
qui s'est passé
en Galate
c'est ça qui s'est passé
dans l'époque de Luther
et même si Luther
était un grand producteur
des traités théologiques
il a fait des commentaires
dans la plupart
des lettres du Nouveau Testament
si ce n'est pas
sa totalité
et la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
une seule lettre
à laquelle il a dédié
deux commentaires
c'est Galate
et il avait un rapport
envers Galate
même si nous pouvons
penser à plusieurs ouvrages
de Luther
qui sont magistrales
mais lui-même
s'il a demandé
quelle est ton oeuvre préférée
sa réponse était
Galate
c'est ma Catherine Vambora
c'est mon épouse
vous avez le nom de son épouse
il dit
j'ai une relation maritale
c'est Galate
qui m'a affranchi
qui est devenue
ma liberté
de tous les poids
des superstitions catholiques
c'est Galate
qui m'a fait comprendre
ma liberté en Christ
c'est Galate
quelque part
qui a décroché
la réforme protestante
c'est bien sûr
par la liaison
entre les thèmes similaires
Romain et Galate
marchent ensemble
à cet égard
mais c'est notamment
par rapport
à l'histoire de Galate
dans la vie de Paul
que nous voyons peut-être
la plus grande importance
car parfois
nous pouvons être
biaisés
comme était
certains disent
que Luther
dans son deuxième commentaire
sur Galate
il voyait l'église catholique
partout
il voulait frapper
l'église catholique partout
et pas sans raison
mais c'est vrai
que son contexte actuel
l'habille
les un peu plus
à voir
les opposants partout
mais Paul
il n'est pas en train
d'écrire à ses opposants
il est en train
d'écrire à son église
son soin
prioritaire
est envers son église
son étonnement
n'est pas citant
les mauvais enseignements
des opposants
son étonnement
c'est que son église
soit susceptible
aux influences
des faux pasteurs
donc c'est important
de donner l'attention
due
à l'aspect
pastoral
de cette lettre
et c'est donc
la contribution
certains l'appellent
cette lettre
comme les grandes
chartres
ou l'épître
magne
de la liberté
en Christ
donc rappelez-vous
les contextes
juifs
la persécution
juive
de Jésus Christ
lui-même
des premiers apôtres
et Paul
au milieu
de ces contextes
qui est appelé
à présenter
les juifs
qui est arrivé
par les juifs
pardon
l'évangile
qui est arrivé
par les juifs
aux païens
double persécution
de la part des juifs
et par là
il a
la confiance
les courage
et la joie
de déclarer
un salut
qui n'a pas besoin
de traverser
les rituels juifs
et il les présente
aux païens
ils sont dans la joie
et Paul
je vous rappelle
quel niveau
de zèle
il avait
vers la loi
il nous raconte
en roman
qu'il essayait
avec tous ses efforts
d'accomplir
parfaitement la loi
il persécutait
l'église des dieux
et si on se rappelle bien
tous les rituels
de la loi
de l'ancien testament
c'était une religion
quelque part
traumatique
terrifiante
qui nous rappelait
à chaque fois
un espoir
les sacrifices
de ces animaux
qui représentaient
un Christ
qui un jour
viendraient
mais jusqu'à ce qu'il ne vienne pas
notre vie était marquée
par transpirer
des rituels
des cérémonies
attachement
à des éléments visibles
les tabernacles
les temples
une vie névrotique
avec Dieu
qui caractérisait
les contextes catholiques
dans lesquels
Luther s'est converti
à un moment donné
avec les mêmes environnements
l'idée d'un Dieu
contre nous
loi
terrifiante
même si la loi
avait un rôle
pour nous conduire
à Christ
si nous sommes
sous la loi
nous sommes terrifiés
par Dieu
la loi
elle était là
pour nous convaincre
de notre incapacité
de l'accomplir
pour chercher
en soi
et maintenant
si les ombres
qui étaient là
qui représentaient
un Christ
qui viendrait
une obéissance parfaite
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
mais que quelqu'un
sera demandé
à faire pour nous
qu'est-ce que Paul
va nous enseigner
en Galate
il va dire
vous êtes païens
vous n'avez pas été
éduqués
dans la loi
des juifs
mais cette loi
était une ombre
lorsque vous voyez
les soleils
éclater
Christ
exposé devant vos yeux
comme crucifié
Christ a en soi-même
une capacité
de nous conduire
à la compréhension
de la loi
plus élevée
que la loi elle-même
donc
n'osez même pas
revenir en arrière
car si vous voulez
car là c'était l'excuse
non non
c'est pas qu'on n'a pas
besoin de Christ
pour être sauvé
c'est juste qu'une fois sauvé
c'est nécessaire
qu'on revienne à la loi
et dire
non non non
si vous voulez revenir
à la moindre goûte
de la loi
rappelez-vous
que vous êtes sous
tous les systèmes
de la loi
si pour se sentir bien
avec Dieu
vous dépendez
de votre performance
parfaite
rappelez-vous
que vous êtes en train
de vous soumettre
à nouveau
dans un rapport
avec Dieu
basé sur vos oeuvres
et si vous
tombez dans
la moindre oeuvre
vous êtes complètement
condamné
et plus que ça
Paul va dire
vous êtes en train
de mépriser
la nécessité
qu'il soit crucifié
car si sa crucifixion
n'était pas suffisante
Dieu n'allait jamais
commettre la folie
d'envoyer
son propre fils
pour mourir
je n'annule pas
la grâce de Dieu
car si la justice
s'obtient par la loi
il s'essuie
que Christ est mort
avant
donc c'est très important
pour nous
de considérer
comment cette lettre
était la lettre
magne de la liberté
en Christ
pour les saluts
mais aussi
pour la continuité
de notre vie spirituelle
et c'est celui-là
donc
les thèmes
centrales
que nous allons
considérer
c'est là où Paul
il va établir
les fondements
de cette compréhension
de la relation
entre l'ancienne alliance
et la nouvelle alliance
la communauté judaïque
et les mouvements chrétiens
la loi
et l'évangile
la lettre
et l'esprit
ce sont des thèmes
qui nous attendent
pour la considération
dans cette lettre
au Galate
donc les thèmes
centrales
c'est l'évangile
de la justification
par la foi
à part les oeuvres
de la loi
défendues
contre
les imposteurs
qui voulaient
nous faire régresser
dans notre liberté
en Christ
c'est important
il y a
trois éléments
principaux
dans la structure
de la présentation
de Paul
les premiers
sous-thèmes
sur ces grands thèmes
de la justification
par la foi
ils commencent
bien sûr
par la défense
de son autorité
apostolique
les premiers
points traités
et c'est important
car là
Paul
il n'est pas en train
de chercher
son autopromotion
ça c'est important
à remarquer
le rôle
de l'apôtre
il est
irréptible
si on peut dire
comme ça
il ne se répète pas
c'est un rôle
inédit
intentionnel
de la part de Dieu
c'est les fondements
tout comme on a eu
douze tribus
qui représentaient
l'ensemble d'Israël
nous avons
douze apôtres
qui représentent
l'ensemble
de la nouvelle alliance
le peuple
Apocalypse
va nous présenter
ces numéros
de la même manière
définis pour toujours
et les grands
désastres
qui peuvent se passer
en termes d'autorité
c'est à nouveau
comme à la réforme
ils ont eu
un problème
qui a été
reconnu
comme l'article
formel
qui permettait
l'église catholique
de nous enseigner
toutes ces fausses doctrines
et qui était
le fait
que la Bible
n'est pas
la seule autorité finale
les papes
sont des descendants
des apôtres
la continuité des apôtres
et les papes
ont l'autorité
aussi
que la parole
de Dieu
ils ont mis
la voix de pape
à l'égalité
avec la parole
de Dieu
mais l'enseignement
biblique
ne permet pas
qu'on l'interprète
comme ça
et c'est un peu
la même chose
qui était en train
de se passer
ces hommes là
étaient
les opposants
étaient des juifs
qui venaient surtout
de Jérusalem
et qui comme
ils étaient habitués
avec
les premiers publics
cibles
de l'évangile
en Israël
à Jérusalem
c'était bien sûr
les juifs
et les juifs
convertis
étaient là
en train de prédominer
dans cette ère
dans cette région
en même temps
en parallèle
Paul était en train
de développer
son ministère
parmi les païens
sauf que certains
qui se sont convertis
ou certains
qui se sont apparemment
convertis
des pharisiens
qui ont trouvé
de l'intérêt
dans certaines doctrines
chrétiennes
comme par exemple
la résurrection
qu'ils croyaient aussi
et les preuves
de la résurrection
du Christ
étaient incontestables
et qui cherchaient
à éviter
la persécution
de la part des juifs
ils pensaient
que s'ils prennent
les chrétiens
juifs
ou s'ils peuvent
juifier
si on peut dire
comme ça
les chrétiens païens
peut-être la persécution
des juifs
va s'arrêter
non ok
ils sont en courant
d'entre plusieurs courants
du judaïsme
qui croient
qu'ils cruent
c'est le Messie
mais au moins
ils gardent les dates
ils gardent la circoncision
etc
et quels étaient
leurs arguments
pour avoir
de l'écoute
ils ont fait
usage de cette stratégie
qui est diabolique
qui est celle
de diffamer
la réputation
de Paul
vous êtes en train
d'entendre
Paul
mais vous savez
il n'était pas
en 12
qui marchait avec Jésus
nous
nous venons
de Jérusalem
et là
on connaissait
les 12
et il réclamait
même avoir
été envoyé
par
les apôtres
de Jérusalem
et donc
Paul
il commence par là
en train de démontrer
je ne vais pas nier
qu'il n'était pas
entre les 12
pendant la vie du Christ
mais il commence
à démontrer
et défendre
son autorité apostolique
ce qu'a fait
les 12 disciples
devenir apôtres
entre autres choses
ce sont les mêmes choses
que Paul a traversé
qui est les Christ
ressuscités
les commissionne
personnellement
directement
qui Christ
fasse reposer
sur les apôtres
l'onction
de son esprit
pour que des miracles
incontestables
intensifs
soient opérés
et surtout
qu'ils soient marqués
par la gouvernance
de son esprit
afin de rédiger
des documents
inspirés
nous sommes toujours
une église apostolique
dans quel sens
que nous croyons
que les apôtres
sont là jusqu'aujourd'hui
non pas du tout
impossible
bibliquement parlant
mais car nous cherchons
au maximum possible
à rester
fondé
sur l'enseignement
des apôtres
et donc
Paul va défendre
son autorité
si nous n'avons pas
l'inspiration
d'écriture
nous n'avons aucune
autorité
toute possibilité
des révélations
car Dieu est libre
libre
Dieu peut nous parler
jusqu'aujourd'hui
mais notre capacité
de discerner
notre capacité
d'interpréter
est faillible
est corrompue
et ne devrait jamais
réclamer autorité
nous devons tout juger
par les écritures
les sans-écrit
l'inspiration biblique
et c'est par là
que commencent
les principaux hérésiques
en mettant en question
l'autorité des écritures
l'autorité apostolique
et quand on contemple
Paul par exemple
qui va dire
même si un ange
ou nous-mêmes
vous présentons
un évangile différent
qu'il soit
malédiction
anathème
je me rappelle
j'étais dans un voyage
au Maroc
et j'ai eu l'opportunité
de partager l'évangile
avec un policier
moussoumant
j'ai eu l'impression
au départ
que c'était lui
qui voulait me convaincre
de sa foi
mais il y a
certains points
où j'ai touché
où finalement
il a dit
non on va s'arrêter là
car je ne peux pas continuer
et l'un des points
c'était celui-ci
comment nous
qui voyons
pendant 5000 ans
au moins 5000 ans
d'histoire
l'autorité
d'une génération
qui réclame
son autorité
basée
sur la génération
précédente
nous voyons comment
la Bible
est compilée
parmi plus ou moins
5000 ans d'histoire
auteurs différents
époques différents
lieux différents
en même thème
aucune contradiction
et là je dis
regarde
quel témoignage
ou quelle attestation
d'autorité ici
et là
quelle était la base
de la révélation
des Maromains
pour qu'il puisse
changer toute sa compréhension
car
quelque part
il avait fait
une rélecture
de la foi
judaïque-chrétienne
d'autres choses
mais quelle était
sa manière
d'interpréter
tout cela
il réclame avoir
vécu
une révélation
d'un âge
qui est venu
de manière subjective
particulière
personne ne peut juger ça
si j'arrive ici
en disant ça
je peux dire
ce que je veux là
si vous m'y croyez
quand j'ai dit
j'ai une révélation
il faut qu'on interprète
tout cela
qui est dans la Bible
de manière complètement différente
je suis la
quatrième personne
de la Trinité
comme on suggérait
certains hérésies
aujourd'hui
des soi-disant
apôtres
de notre génération
si nous sommes esclaves
de l'autorité
réclamée par ces personnes-là
basée sur des révélations
des visions
nous sommes complètement perdus
mais la Bible
elle est confirmée
nous avons besoin
des écritures
nous baser sur les écritures
l'autorité des écritures
donc Paul va défendre
non car
il est intéressé
tout simplement
à s'autopromoua
non c'est car
les fondements
de la foi
des personnes
qui étaient en train
d'être trompées
pour se perdre
ces fondements-là
étaient attachés
à la commission
qui Paul lui-même
avait reçu
il est en train
de protéger
son office
apostolique
et pas tout simplement
sa personne
c'est pas par un gueule
il suffit d'aller
vers Corinthien
pour dire
je parle comme on fout
lorsque je raconte
mes vertus
etc
aucun intérêt d'orgueil
Paul il est là
en train de faire
la défense
de son apostolat
pour qu'on ne soit pas
susceptible
à suivre
les positions
des faux apôtres
donc comme on a déjà
bien présenté
les thèmes centrales
donc il défend
son autorité
pour pouvoir
rassurer
que son message
à propos de l'évangile
était clair
donc les thèmes centrales
ce qui va prendre
les centres de la lettre
c'est la claire compréhension
de l'évangile
exclusive
et suffisante
pour nous sauver
à nouveau
si vous reconnaissez
que vous avez été sauvé
par Christ
mais que vous revenez en arrière
pour essayer
de mener vos relations
avec Dieu
basées sur les oeuvres
rappelez-vous
vous êtes complètement
sous la loi
et vous êtes condamné
par la loi
et donc là
Paul
il est en train
de démontrer
de manière très claire
la justification
par la foi
donc on n'a pas
le temps
de développer
ces points
maintenant
on aura l'occasion
dans les prochains
sermons
Galate 3.10
il dit
car tous ceux
qui s'attachent
aux oeuvres de la loi
sont sous la malédiction
car il est écrit
maudit
et quiconque n'observe pas
tout ce qui est écrit
dans les livres de la loi
et ne l'est même
pas en pratique
donc si on n'est pas disposé
à obéir toute la loi
on ne peut pas considérer
qu'on puisse
vivre
basé
sur la loi
donc
la justification
par la foi
elle parle de notre
position devant Dieu
statut
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
position
et surtout
position légale
c'est là où
on peut reconnaître
comment la formation
romaine
légale
juridique
des Paul
est importante
car
d'être justifié
c'est une déclaration
faite par les juges
celui qui a besoin
de justifier
c'est celui
qui est condamné
et comment nous sommes
justifiés
c'est car un autre
nous a représentés
il a vécu
parfaitement
notre place
et il a aussi
souffert
la punition
qu'on méritait
donc les juges
il peut
nous regarder
aujourd'hui
nous prendre
de cette position
qui représente
condamnation
nous enlever
de cette position
qui représente
condamnation
et nous mettre
dans une nouvelle position
on a compris
et Paul va développer
ça aussi
que Jésus
non seulement
nous a quittés
d'une position
de condamnation
pour une position
de juste
mais il nous a quittés
d'une position
de condamnation
pour nous placer
dans la position
des fils
mais c'est notre affaire
encore à nous
délecter
mais la réalité
c'est que
ok
donc Dieu
il devrait me trater
comme condamné
mais il m'a mis
dans une position
de juste
comment il a pu faire ça
devant les exigences
de juste et salaire
il a fait ça
car il a pris
terme
imputation
ok
attention
il a pris
une justice parfaite
qui n'était pas la mienne
et il a placé sur moi
la justice parfaite
du Christ
et il a pris
la condamnation
que je devrais souffrir
et il a placé
sur Christ
Christ
lorsqu'il s'est mis
dans ma position
il a dû souffrir
ma condamnation
et par la foi
je m'ai mis
dans la position
du Christ
donc c'est que
je reçois des dieux
c'est sa grâce
son amour
je suis déclaré juste
s'il me manque encore
quelque chose à accomplir
c'est car je suis en train
de dire
Jésus Christ
n'a pas accompli
toute la loi
s'il me manque encore
quelque chose à souffrir
cette idée d'un Dieu
encore contre nous
qui nous rend névrotique
dans la dépendance
de ne pas rater
un dimanche
dans cette chaîne
des rencontres
qu'on ne peut pas rater
sinon la promesse
ne vient pas
si j'ai encore besoin
des matériels
des choses
qui peuvent me faire
sentir plus sain
ou dans une meilleure
condition devant Dieu
qui peuvent avoir
des racines superstitieuses
que ce soit
de ne pas rater
les dimanches en culte
que ce soit
faire partie
des chambres de guérison
ou peu importe
comme vous l'appelez
tout rapport
envers Dieu
qui suggère
que nous avons besoin
de notre performance
ou des éléments
matériels
rituels
je vais dire
même plus
car Galate
il voulait garder
des dates
avec un poids
des lois
et aujourd'hui
c'est étonnant
car parfois
on ne veut
ne pas garder
des dates
comme si c'était
une oeuvre à accomplir
et il faut qu'on fasse attention
car notre performance
devant Dieu
va dépendre aussi de ça
bien sûr
que nous ne pouvons pas
garder des dates
en pensant
que cela va nous rendre
mieux avec Dieu
mais nous pouvons profiter
des occasions
de certaines dates
comme Noël
comme Pâques
pour nous rappeler
comment ces choses
s'accomplissent
parfaitement
Jésus Christ
et si je m'oppose
à tel point
que si je participe
je suis gêné
devant Dieu
c'est aussi
un indice
de l'égalisme
peu importe
quelle est la manière
dont on pense
que notre performance
puisse rajouter
quelque chose
à l'obéissance
parfaite du Christ
ou diminuer
l'obéissance
parfaite du Christ
nous sommes en train
de revenir en arrière
de diminuer
notre liberté
en Jésus Christ
et le dernier thème
c'est que Paul
va faire la liaison
non seulement
pour notre salut
nous avons besoin
d'une justice parfaite
vécue pour nous
mais pour la continuité
de notre foi
et c'est là
où il va démontrer
par exemple
c'est là
où on va voir
les premiers fondements
dans les nouveaux testaments
et cette doctrine
plus claire
entre les rapports
du Saint-Esprit
et notre sanctification
donc la justification
par la foi
nous a changé
des positions
définitivement
pour toujours
devant Dieu
si nous sommes en Christ
le salut
est assuré
pour toujours
car c'est son obéissance
parfaite
il ne va jamais manquer
en même temps
ces changements
de position
par imputation
donc quelque chose
qui n'est pas mienne
mais qui est accrédité
comme si c'était mienne
elle est raccompagnée
d'une transformation
Dieu nous a infusé
il a ingété
si on peut dire comme ça
il a changé
notre nature
la sémence
du Saint-Esprit
est en nous
et cette nouvelle naissance
progresse
et voilà pourquoi
Paul va dire
vous avez reçu
les Saint-Esprits
par la lettre
de la loi
ou par les oeuvres
ou par la prédication
de la foi
il va présenter
les fruits de l'Esprit
c'est à dire
notre nouvelle nature
va volontairement
naturellement
si nous sommes véritablement
justifiés
nés de nouveau
il n'y a pas
de possibilité
qu'avec toute cette
emphase là
sur le fait
que nous sommes sauvés
qu'est par Jésus Christ
les personnes
soient sous les risques
de tomber dans la débauche
de faire de la licence
pour tomber dans les péchés
il ne faut pas avoir peur
de ça
car si nous sommes
véritablement justifiés
il y a une nouvelle nature
qui est rentrée en nous
et à partir de là
nous allons progresser
en méditant encore
sur l'œuvre du Christ
donc justification
par la foi
basée sur l'autorité apostolique
justification par la foi
pour notre salut
pour la continuité
c'est pas que l'absence
de la vie chrétienne
c'est l'alphabet en entier
qui a vécu
par la contemplation
de ce qui Christ a fait
pour nous dans la croix
et donc j'espère
que vous soyez aussi
encouragés
que moi
pour continuer
à étudier cette lettre
après avoir considéré
cette introduction
ensemble
Amen
et vons-nous pour prier
à la fin